We, for a very long time, have
thought that if we had found
the secrets of DNA, we could
find the secret of life.
We would be able to know exactly
everything about that
human being, because all the
information should be encoded
in the genome.
It's the blueprint of life.
Unfortunately, we still don't
know exactly how those four
letters' combinations
make everything that
we see around us.
So DNA sequence, the genome,
is not the whole answer.
And chromosome 11 has helped us
to understand that there is
something else besides the
sequence of the bases on the
DNA that is important for the
expression of these genes.
Now if we think about what
happens when a child is born,
then you have one of these
little arms that comes from
the mother and one of
these arms that
comes from the father.
They come together, and they
have in exactly the same
positions exactly
the same genes.
We usually always have two
copies of the same gene.
And for the most part, they
are always both working.
But there are a few
exceptions.
One of them is chromosome 11.
One needs to be on, and the
other needs to be off.
And the mechanism that makes
this copy silent is what
interests me.
It's called an epigenetic
mechanism.
It's a way by which the sequence
of the DNA that is
there, although intact, not
changed, is just marked in a
special way with what we
call epigenetic marks.
And those marks tell that
sequence not to be
read, not to be on.
And that means that you can have
exactly the same DNA in
two cells, as we do, and the
same sequence being expressed
in one cell and not being
expressed in another cell,
making those two cells
different, although they have
exactly the same information,
exactly the same blueprint.
What creates this opportunity
is what we call epigenetics.
If you think about the DNA, all
the bases of the DNA, as
the letters in a book, if you
have just the letters, if you
have no punctuation marks, no
spaces between the words, you
really don't know how
to read that page.
Without the emphasis, without
the pauses when you read a
text, you still cannot get
the full meaning of
what's going on.
So epigenetics gives a layer
of understanding, of
interpretation, of the
underlying genetic code or
genome that we all have.
In the case of chromosome 11,
it's quite obvious that it is
important to have the epigenetic
marks in the right
place at the right time, because
it gives you a very
serious syndrome if you don't.
So there are some examples that
seem to show that the
environment can affect
epigenetic marks in a quite
enduring and long term way.
One example is nutrition.
So the abundance of food for a
period of time can have a big
influence in the expression
of certain genes.
And that is usually controlled
by epigenetic marks.
This can then stay as a
memory of that event.
And they can be passed on to our
children, and probably to
our children's children
as well.
So chromosome 11 was and is a
very important tool still to
study how these epigenetic
modifications can actually
control the expression
of genes.
And the future will tell where
this will take us.